and finally new rule if this sort of
brazen larceny is concerning to you
then you might want to look at how much
of the trillions of dollars in free
government coveted relief money
was just flat out stolen
viewer warning what you're about to hear
may be triggering and if it's not it
should be
let's start with what we spent the
checks the government sent out to get
america through the pandemic there was
the family's first coronavirus response
act for 192 billion the payment
protection program for 484 billion the
consolidated appropriations act for 900
billion the american rescue plan for 1.9
trillion and the cares act for 2.2
trillion although for how much of that
money actually made it into employees
pockets they should have called it the
who cares act
all told
all told 5.7 trillion laid out now
certainly some large amount of spending
was necessary to avert catastrophes like
hospitals being overrun or falling into
a depression so we can argue another day
if that 5.7 trill was the right amount
but for today let's just look at what
happened after the forever flu hit
america
and washington's answer was a mountain
of money and a sign that said come steal
it
872 billion went out to unemployment
assistance you know how much of it went
to improper payments and fraud
well they don't have a solid figure that
would require accounting
but the low end estimates are
163 billion in fraud the inspector
general says it's likely higher than
that and id dot me an insurance fraud
prevention service estimates the number
is closer to 400 billion that's almost
half of it
in one instance two million dollars in
unemployment checks got sent to one
address what was the job that guy was
out of
in arizona scammers got nearly 30
percent of the benefits and that's
arizona where the most fiscally
conservative penny-pinching republicans
used to live
republicans at least you used to pretend
to be the mean old man who watched your
money
but now nobody from either party even
pretends to
defunding the police yes that's a bad
idea but so is de-policing the funds
palm beach thank you one guy
[Music]
palm beach florida which has 160 golf
courses got covered money what'd they do
with it they built a golf course
several non-profits overseen by an
organization called feeding our future
got 65 million to feed needy children
during the pandemic but it was actually
a massive fraud and the fbi says
almost none of this money was used to
feed children
that's like something trump would do
even the poor kids were like if we
wanted to get [ __ ] this bed we could
have gone to church
the paycheck protection program ppp
was designed to help small businesses
pay their laid off employees but
hundreds of loans went to fake farms in
areas where farming isn't even done
you know that saying don't have a cow
they literally didn't have a cow
[Applause]
the government sent 1.4 billion in
stimulus payments to
a million dead people
this woman used covent cash to hire a
hit man and i assume the guy who got
whacked then got a check
we gave billionaire kanye west millions
so he could continue making the world's
ugliest shoes
tom brady's company tom brady's company
got a ppp loan because you wouldn't want
to have him
touch his savings
turns out the
turns out the poor guy couldn't even
retire
[Music]
the shuttered venue operators grant
program gave out 10 million dollars to
broadway's west side story no wonder
they're singing i want to live in
america
and
in another broadway show harry potter
and the cursed child also got 10 million
because jk rowling was living in her car
here in l.a lots of people actually do
live in their car
so six years ago we passed a bond
program to provide housing for the
homeless a couple of months later it
came out that each unit would cost 350
000
and we were all shocked because that's a
lot of money to throw at a problem even
here in california
by 2020 the cost had risen to 531
000 per unit
now it's
837 thousand
for one unit you know in france the land
of high taxes and socialism
857 000 will buy you this
okay that is 20 000 more but it does
have a pool
you know
there's an old adage that government
cannot transfer money except by means of
a leaky bucket and i get that
i get that some amount of leaking is
inevitable but when it's all holes it's
not a bucket anymore what you got there
is a handle
a january new york times article about
the effectiveness of the ppp program
says overall
the ppp was extremely inefficient only
about a quarter of the money spent by
the program paid wages that would have
otherwise been lost
it didn't primarily go to workers who
would have lost jobs it was effectively
a windfall for business owners on the
whole a wealthy group okay
shouldn't liberal democrats therefore be
the ones who are most upset about this
who do you think is most getting [ __ ]
by all this graft and thievery
if i say
you know the government they take our
money and waste it people say you sound
like a conservative but again i haven't
changed the whole to bucket ratio
that changed
should i never notice that change to
keep my progressive card should i stay
supportive of government transfers of
money until the percentage that's stolen
is i don't know unlimited what if they
start to shoot money out of a t-shirt
cannon
still good
you know
i guess these days that these two are
seen as the bad guys in their party
because they looked at another
multi-trillion dollar spending bill and
wondered if our government was up to the
task of taking all that money and not
just having it siphoned off by grifters
and four [ __ ]
would it surprise you that the six
billion earmarked for carbon reduction
in that bill doesn't actually mandate
any carbon reduction
it will pay for new street lights and
bike trails though
you know i know when the numbers get up
into the billions and trillions our eyes
glaze over and it doesn't seem real
so by way of analogy let's return to our
friend in aisle three at the walgreens
okay the walgreens that's the united
states government
and aisle three
that's the 5.7 trillion in coveted
relief
and this guy's shoveling it into a bag
and walking out that's all the
boondogglers and con men in america who
fleece the system
and this security guard who's just
watching it
that's your congressman
[Applause]
you